[Musique]
beaucoup de conférences pour que j'ai
j'ai regardé pour préparer celle ci
commençait par une question et en
général c'est ça qui m'intéresse alors
comme c'est ma première conférence je
vais m'inspirer de ce que j'ai vu et
j'ai commencé par vous poser une
question
que voyez vous c'est facile comme
question en même temps est-ce un peu
piège voyait la personne qui est en face
de vous qui vous voit pas et qui vous
demande ce que vous voyez il ya plein de
réponses possibles justement vous avez
quelqu'un en face de vous qui qui vous
voit pas et qui est obligé de vous
parler vous qui vous voyez vous pouvez
pas parler ça c'est sympa dans la
communication c'est chouette
quitte à parler ben je vais parler d'un
sujet que je maîtrise j'ai essayé de
vous transmettre un petit peu tout ce
que tout ce qui peut m'anime et david
vous de la dit à l'instant j'ai j'ai
plusieurs vies j'ai plusieurs visages et
puis je vous qui avez vu le le programme
avait un peu pris de l avance savez que
je suis kinésithérapeute que j'aspire à
devenir journaliste et que je suis
cavaliers de saut d'obstacles en
compétition alors toutes ces choses là
évidemment je vous en parlais je vous
parlais du cavalier mais j'aimerais
d'abord vous expliquer comment est né ce
cavalier dans les deux sens du terme
bien sûr sens littéral et et
métaphorique
moi je suis né à bordeaux de parents
marocains donc autant vous dire que la
différence
je connais un rayon j'étais déjà pas mal
fourni et je suis au ciné avec une
particularité
j'ai été livré avec un défaut c'est à
dire que génétiquement parlant j'ai été
mal programmées j'ai eu un un défaut
génétique une petite anomalie qui s'est
traduite par un cancer cancer de la
rétine ce mot là il fait peur et
flippant cancer elle a dit qu'il fait
qui fait mourir les gens
bah j'ai eu de la chance moi au bout de
deux à peu près un an et demi de soi
j'en suis sorti avec eux voilà avec un
peu de vision - à force de beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de chimio beaucoup de
chirurgie
là j'étais un petit gamin de deux ans
qui va restant visuelle alors ça c'est
le mot préféré des médecins à l'époque
en restant visuelle aux yeux de la loi
et de la médecine j'étais aveugle mais
j'y voyais voyez c'est déjà la pareille
la différence truc assez sympa j'y
voyais pour rejetter aveugle
j'y voyais quoi finalement je ne pouvais
pas évidemment pas conduire je pouvais
pas lire
donc il a toujours fallu trouver un
autre moyen d'enseigner donc j'ai
toujours appris le braille
par contre j'ai toujours pu avoir les
mêmes repères que vous visuel morneau
j'ai pu repérer des visages des formes
des couleurs je sais quoi ressemble le
ciel je sais voilà à quoi ressemble pas
mal de choses et je sais quoi ressemble
le monde finalement j'ai eu cette chance
là et j'ai eu une autre chance c'est
celle de d'évoluer dans le même monde
que vous c'est à dire que j'ai intégré
une école tout à fait classique dans
laquelle la seule chose différente
c'était le l'institutrice qui
connaissait le braille et qui nous est
court à d'autres élèves et moi qui nous
enseignait bras évidemment fallait bien
apprendre à lire et on n'avait pas les
moyens technologiques qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui
donc j'ai dû apprendre sur des grosses
feuilles cartonnées avec des machines à
écrire qui voilà qui soit assez costaud
qui font beaucoup de bruit donc autant
vous dire qu'on passait pas inaperçu
mais une fois fini les cours finalement
dans la cour de récréation on était on
était comme tout le monde quoi on était
ces gamins qui jouent aux billes qui
font de la corde à sauter qui jouent à
chat alors par contre il y avait un
platane il était pour nous mais peu
importe peu importe il y avait là
firmery pour ça comme pour tous les
autres voilà il suffisait de ne pas trop
se faire mal et puis de la de repartir
je vous parle pas de ça par hasard je
crois que le fait d'avoir été mis avec
tout le monde
finalement personne ne s'est posé la
question et pas moi non plus à l'époque
ça allait de soi et ça m'a permis de
finalement me mesurer aux autres
selon les mêmes critères alors certes
mes parents m'ont toujours appris qu'il
me faudrait beaucoup plus de temps pour
faire les mêmes choses et est beaucoup
plus d'efforts il faudrait que je
travaille 10 x 15 x 100 fois plus pour
arriver au même résultat mais c'est ce
que j'ai fait ce que j'ai tenu à faire
c'est ce qu'on m'a transmis c'est mon
bagage
et deux jours où j'ai tenu à faire
d'équitation ou josé à peine rêver de de
compétition et de tout ça le travail
finalement a été le même et on a réussi
à obtenir ce que vous ce que vous avez
devant vous on a réussi à travailler
dans le même sens que les autres quand
j'ai commencé l'équitation
j'étais un cavalier comme les autres il
a fallu un petit bout de temps pour
trouver un club qui acceptent de jeu de
jeu mais finalement j'avais pas grand
chose de différent j'étais un débutant
tout aussi peu doué que les autres et on
a du mal à prendre de la même manière
qu'on a appris aux autres avec quelques
indications en plus certes mais on a
appris de la même façon là vous voyez
jouer avec pas montre pas ce que je vaux
pas le timer alors du coup j'ai une
petite montre assez sympa voiliers qui
vibre et comme ça l'air de rien mais je
peux vous dire qu'il reste à peu près
six minutes à m'écouter voit la petite
parenthèse et cet apprentissage que j'ai
fait un gros début j'étais juste un
gamin qui voulaient occuper ces samedi
après midi qui osaient à peine dire à
tout le monde qu'ils voulaient faire du
cheval
et souvenez-vous j'y voyais encore un
moment donné bon j'ai dû déménager
charge chercher un autre club et je suis
tombé sur quelqu'un alors on me dit
souvent je suis malade moi de faire du
cheval un mec qui voit rien qui se met
sur une grosse bébête de 500 kg pour
sauter des bars à regarder où il va me
revoilà je suis tombé sur quelqu'un
d'encore plus fous cloyes s'appelle
tiffany s'est massé ma coach depuis dix
ans et c'est elle qui dès que je suis
arrivé m'a dit toi mon coco je vais pas
te lâcher et je vais te faire faire de
la compet
c'est en rêve tu vas le faire on a
travaillé pendant longtemps elle était
juste et la monitrice à l'époque et je
crois qu'on avait le même rêve on avait
cette volonté de nous mettre tous les
deux sur les mêmes mesures que tout le
monde soit sur la même échelle que
n'importe qui et ce travail
finalement ça a donné ça ça a donné
quelque chose qui ressemble à ce que
fait n'importe qui n'importe quel
cavaliers de saut d'obstacles j'ai
enchaîné un parcours il ya pas longtemps
sur le longines master's de paris gros
événement équestre
et je défais sous le parrainage de
guillaume canet qui ont canal fois que
j'ai rencontré
voilà j'ai que 25 ans moi j'étais encore
jeté tout doux gêné je vais d'imhoff
s'intéresse à ce que je fais et j'ai eu
la chance aussi d'être soutenus par des
cavaliers olympiques mais tout juste
médaillés de rio l'été dernier
j'y croyais appel ce que ce que ca va
montrer finalement c'est que ce que les
gens ont vu ce jour là c'est un cavalier
un cavalier qui certes ne vois pas qui a
besoin de personne pour le guider sur le
terrain et finalement les fautes sont
les mêmes le contrat technique elle-même
et le cheval n'est pas dressée
spécialement pour j'ai eu quelques
difficultés en début de tour ça s'est
réglé enfin tout le monde a bien vu ce
qui s'était passé finalement j'ai été
jugées de la même manière que tout le
monde et c'est ça qui m'a énormément plu
finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
je tire comme le sombre de tout cela
c'est que l'important c'était pas la
différence qui saute aux yeux
là en première première vue vous voyez
un aveugle devant vous n'ayez on va
perdre et vous voyez un aveugle je crois
que déjà c'est une erreur de dire que je
suis un aveugle certes je suis avec moi
je ne suis pas que ça j'y pense pas tous
les matins j'ai failli vous dire en me
regardant dans la glace mais ça marche
pas j'ai perdu ce restaurant visuel la
première année où j'ai fait de la
compétition ça ne m'a pas empêché de
continuer je me suis même sorti libéré
j'ai pu me fier à d'autres d'autres
petites choses faites l'expérience
fermer les yeux et vous verrez que votre
visage se tourne malgré tout vers là
d'où vient le son c'est pareil pour moi
dans la vie c'est une partie que la
manière finalement se repérer dans la
ville c'est un peu imaginez vous un
paris en pleins champs elysées quelqu'un
qui vous bande les yeux qu'il faut
tourner trois fois d'affilée vous dit
vas-y est trop longtemps je pars
maintenant on va rigoler voilà donc
c'est exactement ça finalement il n'y a
pas de difficultés insurmontables et il
n'y a pas besoin de s'enfermer dans des
cases c'est peut-être ça aussi qui ne va
jamais arrêté dans mes divers
vie dans les divers passion les jeux
paralympiques qui ont été inventés qui
en 1960 et bien avant cela est une
personne qui n'a pas attendu qu'on lui
explique qu'ils auraient un jour des
compétitions pour les personnes
handicapées georges either l'américain
en 1904 qui a décroché 6 médailles en
une journée
trois médailles d'or deux médailles
d'argent une médaille de bronze en une
journée pour les états unis
c'est un gymnaste avec une jambe de bois
quelque chose d'assez sympa j'aurais pu
m'en servir d'exemple mai mais comme
tous les gamins
j'avais moi d'autres d'autres exemples
en plus je pouvais regarder la télé
j'avais un chamboule tout j'ai eu comme
tous les gosses wade d'autres modèles et
un modèle notamment qui est qui est un
héros qui est un super héros qu'on
surnomme l'homme sans peur qu'ils aient
vocal jour justicier la nuit et
daredevil que vous connaissez évidemment
pas ce que j'ai appris daredevil c'est
que finalement nos barrières n'en sont
que parce qu'on leur permet d'en être
que on peut tout à fait être à la fois
notre plus grand adversaire est notre
plus grand allié
l'important étant de ne pas être son
pire ennemi de ne pas faire malgré soi
et de fer avec soin et partant de là on
peut rêver de n'importe quoi n'est pas
sûr d'y arriver juste pour rester sur
les jeux de mots vous m'avez saisi
j'aime bien les jeux de mots je vois pas
où je vais mais ça m'empêche pas d'y
aller et j'ai envie de vous demander
maintenant que voyez vous je remercie
on va pas fouiller en temps je vous
rassure c'est ma canne tout va bien mais
il n'y a pas de hasard non plus le jour
où ça vient pas d'une boutique
spécialisée pour le pour le clin d'oeil
j'ai acheté ça dans une armurerie un
aveugle dans une armurerie soit encore
c'était génial cela beaucoup fait rire
parce que je voulais un truc sympa pour
makanera jeu et puis bon ski a pas un
petit clin d'oeil à daredevil je vous
laisse libre
l'imagination
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]